The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu
ROBERT GALLAGER: OK so today
we're going to review a little
bit Little's theorem--
we're going to review it a
little bit, but say a few new
things about it.
I want to say something about
Markov chains and renewal
processes, because one of the
most valuable things about
understanding both is that you
can use renewal theory to
solve an extraordinary number of
Markov chain problems, and
you can use Markov chains
to solve an awful
lot of renewal problems.
And I want to make that clear
today because it's a trick
that you have perhaps seen in
the homework, or perhaps
you've missed it.
If you missed it you've probably
done a lot of extra
work that you wouldn't have
had to do otherwise.
But it's a very, useful thing.
So it's worth understanding
it.
Finally we'll talk a little
bit about delayed renewal
processes at the end.
What we will say essentially is
there's a long section on
delayed renewal processes, which
goes through and does
everything we did for ordinary
renewal processes, and as far
as almost all the asymptotic
properties are concerned,
they're exactly the same.
It's just modifying a few of
the ideas a little bit.
The essential thing there is
that when you're looking at
something asymptotically, and
the limit as t goes to
infinity, what happens in that
first little burst of time
doesn't really make much
difference anymore.
So we will talk about that
if we get that far.
OK, one of the main reasons
why convergence with
probability 1 is so important,
you've probably wondered why
we're spending so much time
talking about this, why we use
it so often?
I would like you get some idea
of why it is often much easier
to use than the convergence
of probability.
So I'm going to give you
two examples of that.
One of them is this initial
thing which we talked about in
the notes also and I talked
about on lecture before.
There's this nice theorem
which says that if the
sequence of random variables
converges to some number--
alpha--
with probability 1, and if f of
x is a real valued function
of a real variable,
that's continuous,
that x equals alpha.
In other words, as you start
converging, as you get close
to alpha, this function
is continuous there.
And since it's continuous there,
you have to get closer
and closer.
That's the essence of that.
So It says that then it's
function of zn, a function of
a random variable, a real valued
function of a random
variable is also a
random variable.
It converges with probability
1 to f of alpha.
That was the thing we use to
get the strong law for
renewals, which says it's a
probability that the limit as
t goes to infinity of n of t of
omega over t is equal to 1
over x-bar with probability 1.
In other words, the probability
of this set of
sample points for which this
limit exists is equal to 1
anytime you get confused by one
of these statements, that
says with probability 1, and by
now you're probably writing
this just as an add-on at the
end, and you often forget that
there's an awful lot tucked
into that statement.
And I tried to put a
little of it there.
Initially when we talked about
it we put more in, saying the
probability of the set of omega
such that this limit
exists is equal to 1.
We state it in all sorts
of different ways.
But always go back, and think
a little bit about what it's
really saying.
Random variables are
not like numbers.
Random variables are far more
complicated things.
Because of that they have
many more ways they
can approach limits.
They have many more peculiar
features about them.
But anyway, the fact that this
theorem holds true it is a
result of a little bit of
monkeying around with n
divided by the sum of n random
variables, and associating
that with an n of t over t.
But it's also associated with
this function here.
So you have the two things.
The thing which is difficult
conceptually is this one here.
So that's one place where we
used the strong law, where if
we try to state a weak law of
large numbers for renewals,
without being able to go from
this strong law to the weak
law, it'd really be quite
hard to prove it.
You can sit down and try to
prove it if you want to, and I
think you'll see that it
really isn't very easy.
So strong law of renewals also
holds if the expected value of
x is equal to infinity.
In this case, understanding
why this is true really
requires you to think pretty
deeply about random
variables--
and have an infinite
expectation
of what that means.
But the idea here is since
x is a random variable--
in other words, it can't take
on infinite values--
except with probability 0.
So it's always finite.
So when you add a bunch of them
you get something which
is still finite.
So that s sub n is a
random variable.
In other words, if you look at
the probability that s sub n
is less than or equal to t, and
then you let t go off to
infinity, the fact that s sub
n is a random variable means
that the probability that
sn is less than or equal
to t goes to 1.
And it does that for sample
values with probability 1 is a
better way to say it.
Here I'm actually stating the
convergence in probability 2,
because it follows from
the convergence
with probability 1.
Since you have convergence with
probability 1, n of t
over t also converges in
probability, which says that
the probability as t goes to
infinity that n of t over t
minus 1 over x-bar magnitude
is greater than epsilon, is
equal to 0.
That's this funny theorem we
proved about convergence with
probability 1.
Set of random variables
implies convergence in
probability.
Here's another theorem about
convergence which is called
the Elementary Renewal
Theorem.
We talked about that, we
proved half of it.
After we talked about talked
about Wald's equality.
And we said the other half
really wasn't very
interesting.
And I hope some of you at
least looked at that.
After you look at it, it's a
bunch of mathematics, and a
bunch of equations.
And it says this--
so we have three limits
theorems about n of t.
About what happens when t gets
large there're this number of
renewals that occur, and
the time n of t.
One of them is a strong
law, which is really
a sample path average.
I'm trying to start using the
words sample path average
instead of time average because
I think it gives you a
better idea of what's
actually going on.
But the strong law is really
a sample path argument.
The weak law--
this thing here about
convergence and probability--
it still tells you quite a bit,
because it tells you that
as t it gets large, the
probability that n of t over t
can be significantly different
than one over
x-bar is going to 0.
This in a sense tells
you even less.
I mean why does this tell
you less than this does?
What's significant thing does
this tell you that this
doesn't tell you?
Suppose we had a situation
where half the time with
probability 1/2 n of t over t is
equal to 2 over x4, and the
other half of the time
it's equal to 0.
That can't happen,
But according to
this it could happen.
The expected value of
n of t over t would
still be 1 over x4.
But this statement doesn't tell
you when you think about
whether n of t over t is really
squeezing down on 1 of
x-bar, it just tells you that
the expected value of it is
squeezing down on
1 over x-bar.
So this is really a pretty weak
theorem, and you wonder
why people spend so much
time analyzing it?
I'll tell you why in
just a minute.
And it's not it's not
a pretty story.
We talked about residual life.
I want to use this which I think
you all understand--
I mean for residual life, and
for duration and age you draw
this picture, and that
is perfectly clear
what's going on.
So I don't think there's
any possibility of
confusion with that.
Here's the original picture of
a sample path picture of a
rival apex, of the number of
arrivals up until time t
climbing up.
And then we look at residual
life, the amount of time at
any time until the next
arrival comes.
This is strictly a sample path
idea, for a particular sample
path, from 0 to infinity, you
look at the whole thing.
In other words, think of setting
up an experiment.
And this experiment you view
with the entire sample path
for this particular
sample point that
you're talking about.
You don't stop at any time,
you just keep on going.
Obviously you can't keep on
going forever, but you keep on
going long enough that you get
totally bored, and say well
I'm not interested in anything
after 20 years.
And nobody will be interested
in my results if i wait more
than 20 years, and I'll
be dead if I wait
much slower than that.
So you say we will take
this sample path
for a very long time.
This is the sample
path that we get.
We then argue that the integral
of y of t over t as a
sum of terms, this is a random
variable here. y of t is a
random variable.
It's a number.
If I put in a particular sample
point, each of these
terms here are random
variables.
The sum of them is a
random variable.
And if I put in a particular
sample point,
it's a sum of numbers.
Now, we did the following
thing with that--
I think it was pretty
straightforward.
You look at what the sum
is up to n of t.
In other words, for a particular
time that you're
looking at, the experiment that
you do is you integrate y
of t-- which is this residual
life function--
from 0 to t.
At the same time, at time t
there's a certain number of
renewals that have occurred,
and you look at 1 over 2t
times the sum of x of n squared,
up to that point, not
counting this last little bit
of stuff here, and then you
upper bound it by this sum,
counting this little bit of
extra stuff here.
And we pretty much proved in
class and in the notes that
this little extra thing at
the end doesn't make any
difference even if
it's very big.
Because you're summing over such
a long period of time.
That's one argument
involved there.
The other argument involved is
really very hidden, and you
don't see it unless you write
things down very carefully.
But it tells you why
the strong law of
numbers are so important.
So I wanted to talk about
here a little bit.
What that says--
I mean the thing that is kind
of fishy here, is here we're
summing up to n of t,
and we don't really
know what n of t is.
It depends on how many arrivals
have occurred.
And if you write this out
carefully as a sample path
statement what is it saying?
Let's go into the next
slide, and we'll
see what it's saying.
For the sample point omega--
let's assume for the moment
that this limit exists--
what you're talking about is the
sum from n equals 1 up to
the number of arrivals that have
taken place up until time
t for this particular
sample point.
And it's the sum of these
squares of these inner renewal
times, and we're dividing by
2t, because we want to find
the rate at which this
is all going on.
We write it out then
as a limit.
of x of n squared over omega
divided by n of t of omega,
times n of t of omega,
divided by 2 2t.
In other words, we simply
multiply and divide
by n of t in omega.
Why do we want to do that?
Because this expression here
looks very familiar.
It's a sum of random
variables.
With the sum of n of t of omega
random variables, but we
know that as t gets large, n of
t of omega gets large also.
So that we know that with
probability 1, as t approaches
infinity, this sum here--
if we forget about that term--
this sum here by the
strong law of large
numbers is equal to--
well in fact by the weak
law of large numbers--
it is equal to the expected
value of x squared.
If we take the limit of this
term, we get the limit of n of
t of omega over 2t.
The strong law for renewals
tells us that is equal to 1
over the expected value of x.
So that gives us our answer.
Now why can we take a limit over
this times this, and say
that that's equal to the
limit of this times
the limit of that?
If you're dealing with random
variables, that's not correct
in general.
But here what we're
dealing with--
as soon as we put this omega in,
we're dealing with a sum
of numbers.
And here we're dealing
with a number also.
For every value of t,
this is the number.
In other words, this is a
function of t numerical
function of t, a real valued
function of t.
This is a real valued
And what do you know about the
limit of a product of two
sequences of real numbers?
If you know a little bit of
analysis, then you know that
you're going to take the limit
of a product, and take the
sequence of that limit, then the
answer that you get is the
first limit times the
second limit.
OK?
I mean you might not recognize
the statement in that
generality, but if I ask
you what it is the sum
of a n times b n?
If we know that the limit of
a n is equal to say, a?
And the limit of b
n is equal to b?
Then we know that this sum here,
in the limit the limit
is n to infinity, it's just
going to be a times b.
And you're going to sit down and
argue that for yourselves
looking at the definition
of what a limit is.
So it's not a complicated
thing.
But you can't do that if you're
not dealing with a
sample path notion of
convergence here.
You can't make that
connection.
If you only want to deal with
the weak law of large numbers,
if you want to say infinity
doesn't really make any sense
because it doesn't exist,
I can't wait that long.
And therefore the strong
law of large numbers
doesn't make any sense.
You can't go through that
argument, and you can't get
this very useful result
which says--
What was I trying to prove?
I was trying to prove that the
expected value of residual
life as a time average is equal
to the expected value of
x squared divided by 2 times
the expected value of x.
This makes sense over
finite times.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ROBERT GALLAGER: Yeah.
No, I want to divide by n.
And then I think that makes
it all right, OK?
Something like that.
Let's see, is that right
the way I have it now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT GALLAGER: Yeah I want
to do that, it's right too,
but if I want to take
the summation--
oh no, the summation makes
it messier, you're right.
The thing I'm trying to state
is the limit as n goes to
infinity of an times
bn, is a times b.
And there are restrictions
there, you can't have limit of
an going to 0 or something, and
the limit of bn going to
infinity, or strange
things like that.
But what I'm arguing here--
I don't want you getting
involved with this because I
haven't really thought
about it.
What I want you to think about
is the fact that you can use
the laws of analysis for real
numbers and whether you've
studied analysis or not, you're
all familiar with those
because you all use
them all the time.
And when you're dealing with
the strong law of large
numbers, you can convert
everything down to a sample
path notion, and then you're
simply dealing with limits of
real numbers at that point.
So you don't have to
do anything fancy.
So this result would
be hard to do in
terms of ensemble averages.
If you look at the end of
Chapter 4 in the notes, you
see that the arguments
there get very
tricky, and very involved.
It does the same thing
eventually, but in a much
harder way.
OK, for the sample point
omega, oh, we did that.
OK, Residual life and duration
are examples of renewal reward
functions, so this is just
saying what we've already said
so let's not dwell
on it anymore.
OK stopping trials.
Stopping trials will
be on the quiz.
The Wald equality will
We will get solutions to problem
set seven back to you,
although we won't get your
graded solutions back to you
before the quiz.
I hope we'll get them
out tomorrow.
I hope.
Yes, we will.
They will be on the web.
Stopping trial is a positive
integer valued random variable
such as for each n, the
indicator random variable
indicator of j equals n.
In other words, the random
variable which takes the value
1 if this random variable j is
equal to 1, takes the value of
0 otherwise.
If that random variable is a
function of x1 up to x of n.
If you look at x1 to x of n,
and you can tell from just
looking at that and not looking
at the future at all
whether you're going
to stop at time n.
Then you call that
a stopping trial.
And we generalize that to look
at a sequence x sub n, x sub 1
to x sub n and some other set
of random variables--
v sub 1 to v sub n.
And the same argument.
If the rule to stop is a rule
which is based on only what
you've seen up until time
n, then it's called
the stopping trial.
Possibly the effect of stopping
trial it's the same
except that j might be a
defective random variable.
In other words, there might be
some small probability that
you never stop, that you just
keep on going forever.
When you look at one of these
problems, you use stopping
rules on, it's not immediately
evident before you start to
analyze it what do you
ever stop or not.
So you have to analyze it
somewhat before you know
whether you're going to stop.
So it's nice to do things in
terms of defective stopping
rules, because what you can
do there holds true
whether or not stop.
Wald's equality then says if
these random variables or a
sequence, IID sequence they each
have a mean x-bar, and if
j is a stopping trial, and if
the expected value of j is
less than infinity--
in other words, if it exists--
then the sum at the stopping
trial satisfied--
the expected value of the sum
equals expected value of x
times the expected value of j.
Those of you who did the
homework this week noticed
three examples of where this
is used not to find the
expected value of s sub j, but
where it's used to find the
expected value of j.
And I guess 90% percent of the
examples I've seen do exactly
that you can find the expected
value of s of j very easily.
I mean you have an experiment
where you keep going until
something happens.
Something happens, this is the
sum of these random variables
reaches some limit.
And when they reach the
limit you stop.
If when they reach the limit
you stop, you know
what that limit is.
You know what the expected value
of s sub j is, because
that's where you stop.
And from that, if what x-bar
is you then know what the
expected value of j is.
So we should really state it
as expected value of j is
equal to the expected value
of s sub j divided by the
expected value of x, because
that's where
you usually use it.
OK this question of whether the
expected value of j has to
be less than infinity or not.
If the random variable x you're
dealing with, is a
positive random variable, then
you don't need to worry about
that restriction.
The only time when you have to
worry about this restriction
is where x can be both positive
and negative.
And then you have to worry
about it a little bit.
If you don't understand what I
just said, go back and look at
that example of stop
when you're ahead.
Because the example of stop when
you're ahead, you can't
use Wald's equality there,
it doesn't apply.
Because the expected amount of
time until you stop is equal
to infinity, and the random
variable has both positive and
negative values.
And because of that, the whole
thing breaks down.
OK.
Let's talk a little bit about
Little's theorem.
As we said last time, Little's
theorem is essentially an
accounting trick.
I should tell you something
about how I got into teaching
this course.
I got into teaching it because
I was working on
networks at the time.
Queuing was essential
in networks.
And mathematicians have taken
over the queuing field.
And the results were so
complicated, I couldn't
understand them.
So I started teaching it
as a way of trying
to understand them.
And I looked at Little's
theorem, and like any
engineer, I said, aha.
What's going on here is that the
sum of these waiting times
is equal to the integral of L of
t, the difference between A
of t and D of t,
as you proceed.
So there's this equality here.
If I look at this next
busy period, I
have that same equality.
If I look at the next
busy period, I
have the same in equality.
And anybody with any smidgen
of common sense knows that
that little amount of business
at the end, about that final
period, can't make
any difference.
And because of that, Little's
theorem is just this
accounting equality.
It says that the sum of the w's
is equal to the integral
of L. And that's all
there is to it.
When you look at this more, and
you look at funny queuing
situations, you start to
realize that these busy
periods can take very long
periods of time.
They might be infinite.
All sorts of strange things
could happen.
So you would like to be able
to prove something.
Now, what happens when you try
to prove it, this is the other
reason why I ignored it when I
started teaching this course.
Because I didn't understand
the strong
law of large numbers.
I didn't understand
what it was.
Nobody had ever told me that
this was a theorem about
sample values.
So I tried to prove it.
And I said the following
thing.
The expected value of
L by definition is 1
over t times the limit.
L is the number of customers
in the system at time t.
So we're going to integrate the
number of customers in a
system over all this period t.
And I'm going to divide
by 1 over t.
Oh my God.
Would you please interchange
that limit in the 1 over t?
I mean it's obvious when you
look at it, that has to be
what it is.
And by this accounting identity,
this is equal to the
limit of this sum from I equals
zero to N of t or
w sub I over t.
With this question of having
omitted this last little busy
period, whatever part of it
you're in when you get the t.
I mean, that's the part
that's common sense.
You know you can do that.
Now lambda is equal to
the limit of 1 over
t times A of t.
A of t is just the number of
arrivals up until time t.
A of t, when we're doing
Little's theorem, counts this
fictitious arrival
at time zero.
Or I should say that the
renewal theory omits as
fictitious the real arrival at
time zero, which is what's
going on in Little's theorem.
So then the expected value of w
is going to be the limit as
t approaches infinity of 1 over
a of t times the sum of w
sub I. I'm going to break that
up in the same way I broke
this thing here up.
It's the limit of t over a of
t times the limit of w sub I
from I equals 1 to
a of t, 1 over t.
Breaking up this limit here
requires taking this sample
pass view again.
In other words, you look at a
particular sample point omega.
And for that particular sample
point omega, you simply had
the same thing as I
was saying here.
And I don't know whether
I said it right or not.
But anyway, that's
what we're using.
It does work for real numbers.
And therefore, what we wind up
with is this, which is 1 over
lambda, and this, which is the
expected value of L, from
this, from the accounting
identity.
OK.
So again, you're using the
strong law as a way to get
from random variables
to numbers.
And you understand
how numbers work.
OK, one more example
of this same idea.
One of the problems in the
homework, problem set six are
problems I thought-- yes.
AUDIENCE: About the previous
slide, that's from [INAUDIBLE]
right?
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Then how--
is there an easy way to go from
there to the [INAUDIBLE]
distributions?
PROFESSOR: Oh, to the
ensemble average.
Yes, there is, but not
if you don't read the
rest of Chapter 4.
And it's not something I'm going
to dwell on in class.
It's---
it's something which is
mathematically messy and
fairly intricate.
And in terms of common sense,
you realize it has to be true.
I mean, if the ensemble average,
up until time t, is
approaching the limit, then you
must have the situation
that that limit is equal to
the sample path average.
The question is whether it's
approaching a limit or not.
And that's not too
hard to prove.
But then you have all this
mathematics of going through
the details of it, which
in fact is tricky.
OK.
So back to mark up change
and renewal processes.
You remember you went through a
rather tedious problem where
you were supposed to use
Chebyshev's inequality to
prove something.
And maybe half of you recognized
that it would be
far easier to use Markov's
inequality.
And if you did that, this is
what I'm trying to do here.
The question is, if you look
at the expected amount of
time, from state I in a Markov
chain, until you return to
state I in the Markov chain
again, and you can do that by
this theory of attaching
rewards to
states in a Markov chain.
What you wind up with is this
result that the expected
renewal time in an ergodic
Markov chain, is exactly equal
to 1 over the steady state
probability of that state.
And if any of you find a simple
and obvious way to
prove that from the theory of
Markov chains, I would be
delighted to find it.
Because I've never been able to
find any way of doing that
without going into
renewal theory.
And renewal theory lets you
do it almost immediately.
And it's a very useful
resolve.
So the argument is
the following.
You're going to let Y1, Y2,
and so forth be the
inter-renewal periods.
Here we're looking at a sample
path point of view again.
No, we're not.
Y1, Y2 are the random variables
that are the
inter-renewal periods.
The elementary renewal theorem
is something we talked about.
It says that the expected value
of n sub I of t divided
by t is equal to 1 over the
expected value of y.
That's the elementary renewal
theorem for renewal theory.
So we've stopped talking about
Markov chains now.
We've said, for this Markov
chain, you can look at
recurrences from successive this
is to state I. That forms
a renewal process.
And according to the elementary
renewal theorem for
renewal processes, this is
equal to 1 over y bar.
Now we go back to Markov
chains again.
Let's look at the probability of
being in state I at time t,
given that we were in state
I at time zero.
That's the probability that n
sub I of t, minus n sub I of t
minus 1 is equal to 1.
That's the probability that
there was an arrival at time
t, which in terms of this
renewal process means there
was a visit to state
I at time t.
Every time you get to state
I, you call it a renewal.
We've defined a renewal process
which gives you a
reward of 1 every time you hit
state I, and reward of zero
all the rest of the time.
So this is equal to probability
of Ni of t minus
Ni of t minus 1.
The probability that
that's equal to 1.
So its expected value of N
sub I of t minus N sub
I of t minus 1.
That's the expected value.
This is always greater than
or equal to this.
This is either 1 or it's zero.
You can't have two arrivals.
You can't have two visits
at the same time.
So you add up all
of these things.
You sum this from n equals 1 up
to t, and what do you get?
You sum this, and it's
a telescoping series.
So you add expected value of
n, 1 of t minus n 0 of t,
which is 0, plus n2 of t minus
n1 of t, plus n3 of
t minus n2 of t.
And everything cancels out
except the n sub I of t.
The I here is just the state
we're looking at.
We could've left it out.
So p sub I, I of t, approaches
pi sub I exponentially.
Because down there, very fast,
it stays very close.
If we sum up over n of them, and
these are quantities which
are approaching this limit, pi
sub I, exponentially fast,
then the sum divided by the
number of terms we're summing
over is just pi sub I also.
So what we have is a pi sub I
that's equal to this limit.
That's equal to the expected
value of n sub I over t.
The elementary renewal theorem
reads out, which is equal to 1
over y bar.
So the expected recurrence time
for state I is equal to
pi sub I.
If you look carefully at what
I've done there, I have
assumed that--
well, when I did it, I was
assuming it was an ergodic
Markov chain.
I don't think I have
to assume that.
I think it can be periodic,
and this is still true.
You can sort that out
for yourselves.
That is the first slide I'll use
which says, whenever you
see a problem trying to prove
something about Markov chains
and you don't know how to prove
it right away, think
about renewal theory.
The other one will say, whenever
you're thinking about
a problem in renewal theory, and
you don't see how to deal
with it immediately, think
about Markov chains.
You can go back and forth
between the two of them.
It's just like when
we were dealing
with Poisson processes.
Again, in terms of solving
problems with Poisson
processes, what was
most useful?
It was this idea that you
could look at a Poisson
process in three
different ways.
You could look at it as a sum
of exponential [INAUDIBLE]
arrival times.
You could look at
it as somebody
throwing darts on a line.
And you could look at it as a
Bernoulli process which is
shrunk down to time zero with
more and more arrivals.
By being able to look at each
of the three ways, you can
solve pieces of the problem
using whichever one of these
things is most convenient.
This is the same thing too.
For renewal processes and Markov
chains, you can go back
and forth between what you know
about each of them, and
find things about the other.
So it's a useful thing.
Expected number of renewals.
Expected number of renewals is
so important in renewal theory
that most people call it m of
t, which is the expected
value, of n of t.
n of t, by definition, is the
number of renewals that have
occurred by time t.
The elementary renewal theorem
says the limit, as t goes to
infinity, of expected value of
n of t over t is equal to 1
over x bar.
Now, what happens here?
That's a very nice
limits theorem.
But if you look at trying to
calculate the expected value
of n of t for finite t, there
are situations where you get a
real bloody mess.
And one example of that is
supposedly in our arrival
interval, is 1 or the
square root of 2.
Now, these are not rationally
related.
So you start looking at
the times at which
renewals can occur.
And it's any integer times 1,
plus any integer times the
square root of 2.
So the number of possibilities
within a particular range is
growing with the square
of that range.
So what you find, as t gets
very large, is possible
arrival instance are getting
more and more dense.
There are more and more
times when possible
arrivals can occur.
There's less and less structure
to the time between
those possible arrivals.
And the magnitude of how much
the jump is at that possible
time, there's no nice
structure to that.
Sometimes it's big, sometime
it's little.
So m of t is going
to look like an
enormously jagged function.
When you get out to some large
t, it's increasing.
And you know by the elementary
renewal theory that this is
going to get close to a
straight line here.
m of t over t is going
to be constant.
But you have no idea of what the
fine structure of this is.
The fine structure can be
extraordinarily complicated.
And this bothered people, of
course, because it's always
bothersome when you start out
with a problem that looks very
simple, and you try to ask a
very simple question about it.
And you get an enormously
complicated answer.
So an enormous amount of work
has been done on this problem,
much more than it's worth.
But we can't ignore it all
because it impacts on a lot of
other things.
So if we forget about this kind
of situation here, where
the inter-arrival interval is
either 1 or something which is
irrational.
If you look at an inter-arrival
interval, which
is continuous where you have
a probability density.
And as a probability density is
very nicely defined, then
you can do things much
more easily.
And what you do to do that is
you invent something called
the renewal equation.
Or else you look in
a textbook and you
find the renewal equation.
And you see how that's
derived.
It's not hard.
I'm not going to
go through it.
Because it has very little to
do with what we're trying to
accomplish here.
But what the renewal equation
says is that the expected
number of renewals up until time
t satisfies the equation.
But it's the probability that x
is less than or equal to t.
Plus a convolution here
of m of t minus x
times d f of x of x.
If you state this in terms of
densities, it's easier to make
sense out of it.
It's the interval from zero to
t, of 1 plus m of t minus x,
all times the density of x dx
This first term here just goes
to 1 after t gets very large.
So it's not very important.
It's a transient term The
important part is this
convolution here, which tells
you how m of t is increasing.
You look at that, and you say,
that looks very familiar.
For electrical engineering
students who have ever studied
linear systems, that kind of
equation is what you spend
your life studying.
At least it's what I used to
spend my life studying back
when they didn't know so much
about electric engineering.
Now, there are too many
things to learn.
So you might not know very
much about this.
But this is a very common linear
equation in m of t.
It's a differential.
It's an integral equation
from which you can find
out what m of t is.
You can think conceptually
of starting out at m of
0, which you know.
And then you use this
equation to
build yourself up gradually.
So you started m
of t equals 0.
Then you look at m of t with
epsilon, where you get this
term here a little bit.
And you break this all
up into intervals.
And pretty soon, you find
something very messy
happening, which is why people
were interested in it.
But it can be solved if
this density has a
rational or plus transform.
Now I don't care about how
to solve that equation.
That has nothing to do with
the rest of the course.
But the solution has
the following form.
The expected value of n
of t is going up with
t as 1 over x bar.
I mean, you know it has
to be doing that.
Because we know from the
elementary renewal theorem
that eventually the expected
value of n of t over t has to
look like 1 over x bar.
So that's that term here,
m of t over t looks
like 1 over x bar.
There's this next term, which
is a constant term, which is
sigma squared of x divided
by 2 times x bar squared.
That looks sort of satisfying
because it's dimensionless.
Minus 1/2, plus some function
here which is just a
transient, which goes away
as t gets large.
Now you have to go through
some work to get this.
But it's worthwhile to try to
interpret what this is saying
a little bit.
This epsilon of t, it's
all this mess we
were visualizing here.
Except of course, this result
doesn't apply to
messy things like this.
That only applies to those very
simple functions that
circuit theory people
used to study.
Because they were relevant for
inductors and capacitors and
resistors and that
kind of stuff.
So we had this most
important term.
We have this term, which
asymptotically goes away.
And we have this term here,
which looks rather strange.
Because what this is saying is
that this asymptotic form
here, m of t, as a function of
t, has this slope here, which
is 1 over x bar as the slope.
Then it has something
added to it.
This is 1 over x bar
plus some constant.
And in this case, it's sigma
squared over 2 x bar
squared minus 1/2.
If you notice what that sigma
squared over 2 x bar squared
minus 1/2 is for an
exponential random
variable, it's zero.
So for an exponential random
variable which has no memory,
you're right back to this curve
here, which makes a
certain amount of sense.
Because this is some kind of
transient at zero, which says
where you start out makes
a difference.
Now, if you look at a--
I mean, I'm using this answer
for simple random variables
that I can understand just to
get some insight about this.
But suppose you look at a random
variable, which is
deterministic.
x equals 1 with probability 1.
What are these renewals
look like then?
Start out here.
No renewals for a while.
Then you go up here.
You're always underneath
this curve here.
You look at a very heavy
tailed distribution
like this thing we--
you remember this
distribution?
Where you have x is equal to
epsilon with probability 1
minus epsilon, and that's equal
to 1 over epsilon with
probability epsilon.
So that the sample functions
look like a whole bunch of
very quick.
And then there's this
very long one.
And then a lot of little
quick ones.
We can look at what that's doing
as far as expected value
of n of t is concerned.
You're going to get an enormous
number of arrivals.
right at the beginning.
And then you're going to go for
this long period of time
with nothing.
So you're going to have this
term here, which is sticking--
let's put you way up here.
OK?
So that now you're starting out
because of this transient
that you're starting out at a
particular instant when you
don't know whether you're going
to get an epsilon or a 1
minus epsilon.
You're not in one of these
periods where you're waiting
for this 1/epsilon
period to end.
Then you get that term there.
Then you get this epsilon of t,
which is just a term that
goes with y.
OK so that's what this formula
is telling you.
Want to talk a little bit about
Blackwell's theorem also.
Mostly talking about things
today that we're
not going to prove.
I mean, it's not necessary to
prove everything in your life.
It's important to prove those
things which really give you
insight about the result.
I'm actually going to prove
one form of Blackwell's
theorem today.
And I'll prove it--
guess how I'm going
to prove it?
I mean, the theme of the lecture
today is if something
is puzzling in renewal theory,
use Markov chain theory.
That's what I'm going to do.
OK.
What does Blackwell's
theorem say?
It says that the expected
renewal rate for large t is 1
over x bar.
OK, it says that if I look at
a little tiny increment here
instead of this crazy curve
here, if I look way out after
years and years have gone by,
it says that I'm going to be
increasing at a rate which is
very, very close to nothing.
I might be lifted up a little
bit or I might be lifted down
a little bit, but the amount
of change in some very tiny
increment here of t
to t plus epsilon.
Blackwell's theorem tries to say
that the expected change
in this very tiny increment here
of size epsilon is equal
to 1 over x bar times epsilon.
The expectation equals epsilon
over expected value of x.
OK?
So it's saying what the
elementary renewal theorem
says, but something
a lot more.
The elementary renewal theorem
says you take n of t, you
divide it by t.
When you divide it by t, you
lose all the structure.
That's why the elementary
renewal theorem is a fairly
simple statement
to understand.
Blackwell's theorem is not
getting rid of all the
structure, he's just looking at
what happens in this very
tiny increment here
and saying, it
behaves in this way.
Now, you think about this and
you say, that's not possible.
And it's not possible because
I've only stated half of
Blackwell's theorem.
The other part of Blackwell's
theorem says if you have a
process that can only take jumps
at, say, integer times,
then this can only change
at integer times.
And since it can only change at
integer time, I can't look
at things very close too,
I can't look at
epsilon very small.
I can only look at intervals
which are multiples of that
change time.
OK.
So that's what he's
trying to say.
But the other thing that he's
not saying, when I look at
this very tiny interval here
between t and t plus epsilon,
it looks like he's saying that
m of t has a density and that
this density is 1 over x bar.
And it can't have a
density, either.
If I had any discrete random
variable at all, that discrete
random variable can only take
jumps at discrete times.
So you can never have
a density here.
If you have a density to start
with, then maybe you have a
density after you're through.
But you can't claim it.
So all you can claim is that for
very small intervals, you
have this kind of change.
You'll see that that's exactly
what his theorem says.
But when you make this
distinction between densities
and discrete, we still haven't
captured the whole thing.
Because if the interarrival
interval is an integer random
variable, namely it can only
change at integer times, then
you know what has
to happen here.
You can only have changes
at integer times.
You can generalize that a little
bit by saying if every
possible value of the
inter-renewal interval is a
multiple of some constant,
then you just scale the
integers to be less
or greater.
So the same thing happens.
When you have these random
variables like we'll take one
value 1 or value square root of
2, then that's where this
thing gets very ugly and nothing
very nice happens.
So Blackwell said fundamentally,
there are two
kinds of distribution
functions--
arithmetic and non-arithmetic.
I would say there
are two kinds--
discrete and continuous.
But he was a better
mathematician than that and he
thought this problem
through more.
So he knew that he wanted to
lump all of the non-arithmetic
things together.
A random variable has an
arithmetic distribution if its
set of possible sample values
are integer multiples of some
number, say lambda.
In other words, if it's an
integer valued distribution
with some scaling on it.
That's what he's saying there.
All the values are integers, but
you can scale the integers
bigger or less by multiplying
them by some number lambda.
And the largest such choice of
lambda is called the "span of
the distribution." So that when
you look at m of t, what
you're going to find is when t
gets larger, only going to get
changes at this span value
and nothing else.
So each time you have an integer
times lambda, you will
get a jump.
And each time you don't have
an integer times lambda, it
has to stay constant.
OK.
So if x is arithmetic with span
lambda greater than 0,
then every sum of random
variables has to be arithmetic
with a span either lambda or an
integer multiple of lambda.
So n of t can increase only
at multiples of lambda.
If you have a non-arithmetic
discrete distribution like 1
and pi, the points at which n of
t can increase become dense
as t approaches infinity.
Well, what we're doing here is
separating life into three
different kinds of things.
Into arithmetic distributions,
which are like integer
distributions.
These awful things which are
like two possible values as
discrete, but they take values
which are not rational
compared with each other.
Points at which n of t can
increase become dense.
And finally, the third one is if
you have a density and then
you have something
very nice again.
So what Blackwell's theorem says
is that limit as n goes
to infinity of m of t plus
lambda minus m of t is equal
to lambda divided by x bar.
OK?
This is if you have
an arithmetic x
and a span of lambda.
This is what we were saying
should be the thing that
happens and Blackwell proved
that that is what happens.
And he said that as t gets
very large, in fact, what
happens here is that this
becomes very, very regular.
Every span you get a little
jump which is equal to the
span size times the
expected increase.
And then you go level for that
span interval and you go up a
little more.
So that what you get in a limit
is a staircase function.
And this is lambda here.
And this is lambda times
1 over x bar here.
OK?
And this might have this added
or subtracted thing that we
were talking about before.
But in this interval, that's
the way it behaves.
What he was saying for
non-arithmetic random
variables, even for this awful
thing like pi with probability
half and 1 with probability
half, he was saying pick any
delta that you want, 10 to the
minus 6, if the limit is t
goes to infinity of m of t plus
delta minus m of t is
equal to delta over x bar.
At density has this behavior,
but these awful things, like
this example we're looking
at, which gets very--
I mean, you have these points of
increase which are getting
more and more dense and
increases which are more and
more random.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this true only for
x bar finite or is this
true even if x bar
is infinite?
PROFESSOR: If x bar
I would guess it's true if x bar
is infinite because then
you're saying that you hardly
ever get increases.
But I have to look at
it more carefully.
I mean, if x bar is infinite,
it says that the limit is t
goes to infinity if this
difference here goes to 0.
And it does.
So yes, it should hold true
then, but I certainly wouldn't
know how to prove it.
And if you ask me what odds,
I would bet you $10 to
$1 that it's true.
OK?
[CHUCKLE].
OK.
Blackwell's theorem uses very
difficult analysis and doesn't
lead to much insight.
If you could code that properly,
I tried to read
proofs of Blackwell's theorem.
I've tried to read Blackwell's
proof, and Blackwell is a guy
who writes extraordinarily well,
I've tried to read other
people's proof of it, and I've
never managed to get through
one of those proofs and say,
yes, I agree with that.
But maybe you can
go through them.
It's hard to know.
But I wouldn't recommend
it to anyone
except my worst enemies.
The hard case here is this
non-arithmetic but discrete
distributions.
What I'm going to do is prove it
for you now as returns to a
given state in a Markov chain.
In other words, if you have a
renewal interval which is
integer, you can only get
renewals at times 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, up to some finite limit.
Then I claim you can always draw
a Markov chain for this.
And if I can draw a Markov chain
for it, then I can solve
the problem.
And the answer that I get is a
surprisingly familiar result
for Markov chains and it proves
Blackwell's theorem for
that special case.
OK, so for any renewal process
with inter-renewals at a
finite set of integer times,
there's a corresponding Markov
chain which models returns
to state 0.
I'm just going to pick
an arbitrary state 0.
I want to find the intervals
between successive
returns to state 0.
And what I'm doing here in the
Markov chain is I start
off at state 0.
The next thing that happens is
I might come back to state 0
in the next interval.
One thinks it got passed
out to you, the
self-loop is not there.
The self-loop really corresponds
to returns in time
1, so it should be there.
If you don't return in time 1,
then you're going to go off to
state 1, as we'll call it.
From state 1, you can return
in one more time interval,
which means you get
back in time 2.
Here you get back in time 1,
here you get back in time 2,
here you get back in time 3,
here you get back in time 4,
and so forth.
So you can always draw
a chain like this.
And the transition
probabilities--
nice homework problem would be
to show that the probability
of starting at i and going to
i plus 1 is exactly this.
Why is it this?
Well, multiply this probability
by this
probability by this probability
probability, and what you get
is the probability that the
return takes five
steps or more.
You multiply this by this
by this by this.
Multiply this thing for
different values of i, and
what happens?
Successive terms--
this all cancels out.
So you wind up with 1 minus
piece of x of i
when you're all done.
Or i plus 1.
OK?
Now here's the interesting
thing.
For a lazy person like me, it
doesn't make any difference
whether I've gotten this
formula right or not.
I think I have it right,
but I don't care.
I've only done it right because
I know that some of
you would be worried about it
and some of you would think I
was ignorant if I didn't
show it to you.
But it doesn't make
any difference.
When I get done writing down
that this is the Markov chain
that I'm interested in,
I look at this and I
say, this is ergodic.
I can get from any state here
to any other state.
I will also assume that it's
aperiodic because if it
weren't aperiodic, I would just
leave out the states 1,
3, 5, and so forth for that
period 2 and so forth.
OK.
So then we know that the
limit is n goes to
infinity of p sub 00n.
In other words, the probability
of being in state
0 at time n given that you
were in state 0 at
time 0 is pi 0.
pi 0 I can calculate.
If I'm careful enough
calculating this, I can also
calculate the steady state
probabilities here.
Whether I'm careful here or not,
I know that after I get
rid of the periodicity here,
that I have something which is
ergodic here.
So I know I can find
those pi's.
Now, so we know that.
pi 0, we already saw earlier
today, is equal to 1 over the
expected renewal time between
visits to state 0.
So with pi 0 equal to 1 over x
bar and this equal to pi 0,
the expected difference between
the probability
renewal of time n and the
probability renewal of time n
minus 1 is exactly 1 over x
bar, which is exactly what
Blackwell said.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you please explain
why this proves the
Blackwell theorem?
I don't really see it.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I proved the
Blackwell theorem because what
I've shown here is that as n
gets large, the probability
that you will be in state 0 at
time t given that you're in
state 0 at time 0-- in other
words, I'm starting off this
renewal process in state 0.
So the probability of being in
state 0 at time n is really
exactly this thing that
Blackwell was talking about.
OK?
Blackwell was saying--
I mean, lambda here is
1 because I've just
gotten rid of that.
So the limit of m of t plus t
plus 1 minus m of t is the
expectation of a renewal
at time t plus 1.
OK?
And that's 1 over x bar.
AUDIENCE: So why is this renewal
process-- why is this
Markov chain model exactly
what we have in renewal?
So you're claiming that we have
a renewal if and only if
we return to state 0 in
this Markov chain.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that's the
thing I don't see.
Is it supposed to be obvious?
PROFESSOR: Oh, you don't
see why that's true?
Let me try to do that.
I thought that at least was
obvious, but as I found as I
try to develop this course,
things which are obvious are
the things which are
often not obvious.
If I have a random variable,
let's say, which takes on the
value 1 with probability 1/2
and the probability 2 with
probability 1/2 and I use that
as the inter-renewal time for
a renewal process, then starting
off in time 0 with
probability 1/2, I will have a
renewal in time 1 and I will
have a renewal in time 2 with
probability 1/2 also.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: That's exactly what
this says if I draw it for--
I don't need that.
AUDIENCE: I see.
PROFESSOR: OK?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Do you mind doing it for a
slightly more complicated
example just so it's easier
to see in full generality?
So it looks like [INAUDIBLE]
values or something.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then this won't be--
let's make this 1/2.
And this 1/2.
OK.
And this--
what is this going to be?
I mean, this has to be
1 at this point.
AUDIENCE: So then this would
take on 1 with probability
1/2, 2 with probability 1/4,
and 3 with probability
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I think so, yes.
AUDIENCE: Good.
Thanks.
PROFESSOR: I mean, this is a
question of whether I've
calculated these numbers
right or not.
And looking at this example,
I'm not at all sure I have.
But as I say, it doesn't
make any difference.
I mean, so long as you buy the
fact that if I don't return in
time 0, then I'm in some
situation where it's already
taken me one unit of time, I'm
not through, I have to
continue and I keep continuing
and that's--
OK?
OK.
And there's--
oh.
I already explained delayed
renewal processes.
I will explain it again.
A delayed renewal process is
a modification of a renewal
process for which the first
inter-renewal interval x1 has
a different distribution
than the others.
And the intervals are all
independent of each other.
So that the first interarrival
period might do anything.
After that, they all
do the same thing.
And the argument here is if
you're looking at a limit
theorem that how long any--
if you're looking at the limit
of how many arrivals occur
over a very long period of time,
the amount of time it
takes this first arrival to
occur doesn't make any
difference.
It occurs at some time.
And after that, it gets
amortized over an enormously
long time which is going
to infinity.
So if it takes a year for the
first arrival to occur, I look
at 1,000 years.
If it only takes me six months
for the first arrival to
occur, well, I still look at
1,000 years, but I mean, you
see the point.
This first interval becomes
unimportant compared with
everything else.
And because of that,
the strong law
still is going to hold.
That says that convergencing
probability also occurs.
All it does as far as m of t
is concerned, the expected
value of m of t, it moves it
up or moves it down, but
doesn't change the slope
of it and so forth.
Even if the expected time for
the first renewal is infinite.
And that sounds very strange,
but that still is true and
it's true by essentially
the same argument.
You wait until the first
arrival occurs.
It has to occur at some point.
And after that, you can amortize
that over as long as
you want, you're just
looking at a limit.
When you look at a limit, you
can take as long as you want
to, and you take long enough
that you wash out the stuff at
the beginning.
I mean, if you told me
that, I would say
you're waving your arms.
But if you read the last section
of the notes and you
summarize it, that's exactly
how you will summarize it.
OK.